hello and welcome to this rapid game on
beaches play bleki against on unless
okay so let's see what happens
I am the Dutch is not one of my main
openings but why not try something else
probably German right
- waiting for a move and five sir such a
shocker solji three finally again I have
six and going form yeah for what exactly
I can go for the Stonewall or form and
or them Leningrad now it's nice okay so
let's go g6 for the landing words 93
actually is some that early makes a
stone wall a bit more attractive but
okay I was originally intending this
anyway some of the big deal white is
really taking a long time for those
moves
okay
just very unlikely that you spot
something better then yeah than this one
but the only thing that you can argue
about here with widest when you look at
the mood waters is if you actually
should play this counselling so early in
some cases it makes sense to play an
early C for D form if you want to play a
B for base set up you can sometimes play
this really really quickly but it's not
yeah not something very essential
okay so b3 this is a good line of course
sd-6 I have to say that I'm basically
making this up as I go along
I don't really know this so I think I
think I can try to play 45 but don't
don't quite like Queenie age 96 and d5 I
think I can try to play for that but
they're probably on board manage jobs
didn't want to do that probably won't
manage White has some couple of ideas
mostly playing for like my biggie - and
then go for you for I wonder ever should
go 96 but peace 55 looks a bit strange
okay I'm going 28 not very sure if this
is correct but it is some fairly normal
looking so we play c4 after all
[Music]
yeah knight c6 d 592 ages probably not
so great now so yes
probably not BD to Quincy to e4 lettuces
idea maybe I can play knight c6 d 598
and then go for a 5 let's try that I
mean this is maybe not the best but but
I don't know anything
yeah that I am can play that I fully
trust so just have to c6 I think it's
certainly an idea but this is
interesting
so he goes 45 so come on 98 and my idea
is to play e5 he takes and then I hit
with the night yeah this isn't such a
bad structure I think the other idea is
to play c5 in this position but my
knight is probably misplaced for this so
I'm doing this it was a pre move
that's cheek with the night maybe Knight
d5 is an idea actually for white no
Queen to c1
okay not entirely sure where is going
with it
so what what is it that I want to do
multiple again
Queens is cluster shot mostly the sake
right maybe Queen c2 was the idea
I'm taking control over d5 and try for
Queen to e7 and rook e8 I actually did
not take into account that that Bishop
e3 is coming so quickly
hmm I was thinking I play hook the aide
and just cover this and then 95 to you
for maybe so nice not that's nice I have
98 to cover that porn but that was not
what I wanted
now this is the structure in itself here
is not that bad there are some lives in
the Dutch where this is happening very
frequently but I think compared to those
lines I'm 10 P down that's the issue
hmm and it's a bit surprising so hmm
what is the point
so and I could take there are a couple
of things that all of a sudden make
sense
94 for example is a move after which you
probably will take bishop Teague and
then my development has been sped up a
lot
maybe Oh am I wrong now let make sense I
mean if he takes visually that has sped
up my development really really a lot
and yeah yeah and now we are getting now
it gets really really funky because I
can't think of awesome aggressive play
already taking in their form 9f2 I mean
and probably not working yet
probably not mmm Bishop h6 also move
that could be interesting probably also
not yet working now if I refer the
normal move I just wonder if Bishop h6
helps me in any way that's probably not
we should pay 622 9f2 king cakes should
III check I think it can take it if not
then would be interesting told me what I
was thinking of just did not work with
this is not not terrible anyways so what
is this I probably have to go back now
f7 not probably to a7
an idea SIA film is a possible idea um
but you create kind of fits into this
position anyway so let's do it
not sure 33 okay did not think about
this so what to do I can just take it
which is definitely not bad the night on
b2 is not really well placed and they
have Queen f6 immediately attacking it
and threatening Bishop takes a form that
cannot be bad ready yeah very likely I
don't have anything substantially better
okay so this should force the Queen back
to d2 or something like that and then I
have booked 88 finally completing my
centralization you know this isn't
ending d5 do I have anything better
only not d5 the idea okay an idea is 96
to e4 then yeah I wonder 55 but it's
just the move that makes the most sense
it does weaken a 5 but mine I don't have
7 is really not that badly placed it
covers all those squares I think and
move that it's er possible he is c5 but
I don't think this is good I think I'm
ok then we'll play on the e-file even
though my knight on f7 looks really bad
done
what do I go d4 actually c5 deform
trying to play Bishop b5
Jim I think I will pay him probably
equal the black bishop
Oh interesting but isn't that a good
ending if I take and take on c4b hard
it's a good ending I also have D pawn to
d4 words this is just good just good for
black I think we have some problems here
with this coordination yeah
Knight takes I can just take and then I
get into the second and context okay
yeah I think I just take the knight and
then play play book and d2 he has will
be three and it's true so let's think
about it for a moment
would be three like a takes takes up to
to be three I have Knight to d6 c5 yeah
that's not really super convincing yeah
it's a little bit less can be less
convincing that thought and okay takes a
look at me okay
and now the - isn't that just good what
is the deal
let's do it I have nine to d6 at some
point this is a really nice position for
the night covering crucial pawns and
looking at this okay so I can take this
now not we're about to look Luke rasa
Luke isn't there some kind of problem if
I take this ship takes c5 look here b5
that seems like it drops the bishop now
it is very well placed on d6
I don't think you can take just one
known if c5 or a5 is more precise now
maybe 85 but that both should work I
think you just realized that he cannot
take on e4 and that makes the position
pretty awkward because I'm threatening
this anyway yeah trapping the rook b5 is
an idea b5 and then drew gets trapped
after you fall instead of taking b5 also
was an idea but I thought he has 85 and
I wasn't totally sure then but I am
still prob maybe that would have worked
but taking is good Jim oh it's not okay
but it should take a long time okay so
we are back unboxing of new chest
materials so we got to a got you in
Chesley a book you in chess magazine
okay
you
yeah and as always in the UN chess
magazine the most interesting thing is
the last page the just checking where
you get to learn stuff about chess class
that you did not know perform this time
it's a Ricard Runner Valley interesting
one of the best Indian players and is
there something very interesting in
there which book would you give dear
friend the secret by Rhonda Byrne I
recently heard about this book the
secret I have to look that up is what
that is okay anyway
a4 was played by my opponent and let's
see yeah III looks most obvious
threatening to shoot so simply promoted
a 5 mm if I go c5 isn't the rook trapped
anyway
c5 trapping the
yeah yeah easiest is to go into that
Holden being a piece oh wow
it was going downhill really quickly um
yeah 23 I think wasn't a state but that
let's have a look at the at the game we
should request computer analysis and see
what happens I'm fairly sure that I
played the opening badly in some way I
mean I don't know the theory and 96 is
probably not the best time thinking
about it Jim
the engine does not dislike it all that
much I think probably something like
this is more more conventional but I
always think that this is very logical
and probably good for William I know I'm
not an expert I'm just I just wanted to
experiment a bit with this opening I
played the laning with Dutch like maybe
15 years ago but it's been so long I
don't really remember details and so
opening 96 probably not that great so d5
went back here 93 I think we can be
quite sure that this is this is fine I
mean once I decided on that this exempt
that it is fine so takes that make sense
if he does not take I think I get a
pretty nice on Kings Indian style
position with f5 being played and this
night is maybe getting a good place
there so
okay tasted that it said is good yeah
Quincy one he wrote mostly yeah um I
assumed he wants to go here which makes
more sense I'm a little bit surprised
that the engine thinks this reason is
about equal its position I thought that
I should be a little bit worse here okay
the engine gives 0.3 but this is this
isn't something um okay so what Quincy
one was played I went to see six what
covering d5 the pawn on d6 is weakened
I woulda thought I'm able to to cover it
I was more of expecting this kind of
thing and the engine gives 94 is it good
no didn't think about that I was
thinking about the eight and this he
goes Bishop a3
I don't understand the questions may
rocky has a question but I don't
understand what he wants sorry yes all
right
[Music]
[Music]
and so um yeah 94 in fact I did not
really take that into account but it
seems good yeah
this is actually there's too much stuff
hanging this is hanging the rookie's
hanging and so on I didn't really see it
that clearly you played that you fine
and this is not helping
we should age six something that I
should have considered actually didn't I
didn't it makes perfect sense l and yeah
and so on but I have no good way to take
this in I mean this is not really really
something that you want most like in the
dark squares being so weaker shop okay I
went 90 form that was not bad he has to
take basically and I get developed yeah
yeah I was briefly thinking about those
sacrificial auctions they don't work I
think but it's interesting to to check
out um of one example yeah Queen c2 this
I know it doesn't work but I just want
to show where this this if he if he has
to go back
I think the
this could be quite dangerous actually
and you for this work okay G for Queen
h4 I was just thinking of those kind of
options are funny to explore it okay it
doesn't simply work in with some
cooperation from right so I went to
inside which is not bad it's a good
square and if he does not play a four I
might go with g5 and for myself so a
four and nine f7 yeah and this is not so
bad here it comes with supporting
squares the pawn on d6 I thought I'm I'm
about about equal here getting a call
okay so I'm let's just quickly okay back
I am back with Emma yeah and so Knight
is covering d6 nicely I think what the
computer says the slight edge is
probably right here forward yeah but
we're a for I think does not really help
the engines suggestion and Queen f2 and
then some before and that make sense
them and I think it probably am is a bit
that up William if it plays before um
yeah I'm solid but nothing nothing great
right a for I think is probably the
first step in giving me equality Queen
f6 right now yeah 92 the engine wants to
go defy
immediately the animator definitely
that's an idea
it's an idea because after eggs takes
cakes cakes this actually looks good for
black this is weak but he has a somewhat
weaker kingside my night is really
better positioned than his line and I
got a group before and I'm just quicker
and putting pressure on this okay it's
nothing special as you see from the
available in all the consideration
so-called 88 you'll see one and now the
acción is kind of not lots of paying
attention I guess because the 5 was was
certainly on the cards through when you
fall maybe was better and I work to
Quincy three are the engine actually
think this is okay for what I was
thinking
I'm already better here this this night
takes the engine to things it's okay
it takes interesting
I was I was more expecting this move and
then I thought of T to be three and yeah
I thought I should be better but doesn't
seem to be the case even have to be six
that fault I would be better but he has
Luke a3 is important I was only thinking
Bishop c6 which makes no sense in
comparison and this is equal according
to the comp
yeah ladle it Bachmann I don't I don't
manage to fix those pawns so it is equal
then it could have played this rather
comfortably but this is also supposed to
be okay I just wonder how I mean before
and if I was cleaning wrong that that's
true but so this was still okay look a4
was supposed to be better yeah okay for
cookie to takes takes and then G for
equal no I was a bit too optimistic
during the game after this and now he
has to pay attention now and if I didn't
do that I already could have played p5
trapping guru you know by f64 wins it's
not like it doesn't win but I could have
done that I saw this but I thought he
might take and what L am but this is
really not a problem
I just Vinnie am pretty easily but okay
e 4f 64 is good I'm threatening to trap
the bookends I also threatened D three
years is the thing after a four I mean a
five and thirty five traps the route but
this is also winning there is simply no
defense here now KF 195 and then I also
saw that line that should also win but
it's not necessary and you can just win
the win the piece basically after c5g to
lay of them we have the winner of a
piece of King takes an ITEX yeah so a
fairly good game actually after looking
at this with the engine not not many not
many mistakes up to this point the white
goddess own rope trapped yeah thanks a
lot for watching until the next video
bye bye